haha the Joe Rogan experience here's
here's the prediction I made you know
very early on I was talking to my
friends actually I think I said this
what they're gonna do they're gonna say
we're only gonna keep things closed
until April 12th and that's what Trump
said at first Easter we're gonna come
open up and I said about a week before
they're gonna say no we got to push it
back
sure enough April 30th then May 15th now
it's June 1st they're to me first for
who I just said I think New York just
announced this they said June 1st yeah
but I think they said they're gonna
start May 15th with outside of New York
City right there's not that Cuomo said
I'm not entirely sure but feel like you
said their goodness I do know a lot of
jurisdictions have slowly entered you
know the phase one there was that Trump
argument with with camp in Georgia about
going too fast and stuff like that yeah
so I guess you know people starting to
realize if you don't open things up
there's nothing to save right right
what's what's freaking to me about all
of this is the tribalism behind whether
or not we should reopen the economy or
stay locked down it's connected to
everything right
what do you mean the tribalism it's
Kelly yeah it's it's it's so you know I
had a friend messaging me saying we're
stupid people who want haircuts are
gonna get us all killed and they're
going out in protesting and and the
first thing I'm like you really don't
think just because one guy was holding
that dumb science what everyone is
thinking right now that's not the case
but what's crazy to me is you had the UN
a UN adviser come out and say we're
looking at a hundred and thirty million
people are going to starve because of
the economic shutdown and that's gonna
be much worse potentially than the
actual pandemic itself and these kind of
facts are ignored because of the
tribalism of what's happening you know
Trump tweets it out therefore it's an
outright left
you know conservative whatever I don't
think they know exactly what to do I
mean I think there's some educated
decisions that are being made by medical
professionals and then they have to
adjust those based on new statistics
that come in and I don't know if they
have adjusted like the the initial idea
was that there was an X amount of people
that were infected in California it
turns out there's many many many more
and the most recent thought is that
there's somewhere around 400,000 now
there has been some dispute about these
studies you know whether or not these
studies are accurate whether or not the
two tests are accurate whether in
you could get it again whether or not
even matters if you've already had it
you might be able to get it again but
there's no adjustments and no one's
saying hey this is way less deadly than
we thought it was going to be you know
there's this sounds like the problem of
government yeah I've never been one of
these small government types I'm you
know as much as people might want to
argue it with me I lean a little bit
left and a lot of issues like government
programs I think are good things it just
seems like whenever the government
enacts something it's so slow to fix it
if it goes bad or when things change
right so so to adjust if they need to
shift back they tend to just dump more
money into it if it's not working
properly I want to know why some people
just shake this off that's to me the
most for this it almost seems like
you're dealing with more than one virus
it's like you're dealing with a bunch of
different versions of a virus I think
you are I think they've they've said
they found multiple strains like that it
changed a little bit or something hmm I
don't want to kind of I know they're
sure I know they did say that about
India they said that the the strain that
they have in India is apparently very
different than the strain they're
experiencing in Europe yeah I think some
I heard something similar about like
Washington they found two strains
liberal and conservative strains yeah
yeah yeah it's the crazy thing to me is
the people a lot of Trump supporters and
I don't want to I'm not trying to
blanket out every single one but there's
some high-profile ones that are really
acting like since the beginning they've
doubted it every step of the way and I'm
like have you looked at the spike charts
if you know here's what I say if in New
York City we're seeing thousands more
dead
what are they dying of if not some kind
of you know infection I mean you can you
can call whatever you want you can act
like nothing's going on but we're seeing
huge spikes and you can tension to them
there's fools no matter what you do is
those gonna be fools so you know it's
obviously a real virus it's obviously
real dangerous it's the tribal ISM yes
it's foolish yeah it's you know you got
to just dismiss that stuff you can't
even debate or dwell on it but what's
interesting to me is well there's a
bunch of parts that are interesting but
what's interesting to me is like who
like George is opened right and then
parts of Montana of opens there's things
that are open in Texas yeah like it's
gonna be interesting to see what the
response is going to be whether or not
they
come back online quicker and their
economy builds up quicker or whether or
not they get a second surge and they've
shut down longer and it winds up being
that maybe should have waited longer and
went ahead less infection like we just
saw a city of ten million in China and
her lock down again did this to what
degree I'm not entirely sure but they've
announced you know reopening all the
social distancing measures and certain
closures and stuff like that and they're
saying it's because someone a student I
think they're saying a student from the
US came back course they're saying right
right right reignited but there's also a
bunch of studies now about reinfection
yeah you know it's it's a lot of we
don't know and everyone's freaking out
whenever there's a new disease and
everybody's got a scramble in real time
to try to figure out what the [ __ ] to do
about it and well just weird it out
everybody's weirded out you know no one
knows like what is normal now
what is what is reality the reality we
live in like you see movies now when
people hug or shake hands and you're
like ah what are you doing I've been
watching these commercials you see these
commercials they're all the same where
it's like it's like we're all in this
together and then it shows people
banging pots and pans and it's like we
may not be able to hug anymore but the
love is there it's like all identical
but then all of a sudden an older
commercial pops up and I was watching
this the other day and it's like a guy
walks up shakes his buddy's hand Pat's
him in the back and then like gives his
wife a kiss on the cheek and I'm like
that's an old commercial that is I can
tell it's an old campaign yeah cuz they
would not do that most of them are old
because you can't shoot anything anymore
yeah you know I don't know how i'm
curious how they're doing these
commercials where they film new york i
guess they're going out in new york and
filming people actually you know cheer
from their balconies and stuff huh look
you know i think there's a real there's
a real tough question know that a lot of
people want to ignore i think there's a
lot of trump supporters who are pushing
it because they're in favor of reopening
the economy but there's like that
equation of at what point is having
things shut down more damaging then you
know so at a certain point we have to
recognize people gonna die no matter
what we do well there's a bloomberg not
not the mayor but there's a bloomberg
statistic on the economy that measures
the downside like when when the economy
goes down how many people die because of
it and you could kind of trace it it's
it's very disturbing and when we're
talking about deaths we're talking
there's something that we can
immediately deal with it's right in
front of us it's a disease it's
happening right now go after it stop it
but the secondary reaction to that in
fact because you're closing the economy
might wind up killing as many people as
you trying to avoid being killing in the
wall hormones yeah so I don't know the
you went the big story on the UN was
that their adviser said 235 million
starving you know in the next year so
unless things kick back into gear
[Applause]